was a very civil meeting we did actually  manage to talk about pay we didn't get  the tangible concessions and that we  might have hoped or that would enable us  to call off the stripes later this week  and and next but it was definitely a  progress we were in a room with the  Secretary of State talking about pay  um I think he's asked for our help to  help with the the treasury to make the  case for investment in in Hay we'll  certainly do that but we didn't get the  tangible outcome that we were hoping  were you talking about Payphone right  now as opposed to the next financial  year so the secretary of state is very  very clear that resolving this dispute  means not just talking about pay for the  next period but actually pay for the  current pay year so very clear that  resolving the dispute will take boosting  pay ahead of the first of April